[Music]
there's gotta be a different good way
for me to me in the twitch world that go
down this fortnight line man coming in
here in front of you guys is the hardest
thing I've had to do in a long time
I know I've done this for years and it
just doesn't make sense to me why why
it's scary to get on why it's scary to
sit here in front of you guys why it's
scary to talk I think I got you know
recently picked up some anxiety issues
where I'm overthinking a lot of things
I'm hoping that once we start gaming who
will be in there you know she's dropping
off some bananas don't worry
The Great Escape into boat transfer and
I'm dropping this connector and slam
this man to death
I like to call that the Maverick moves
in our own defense with these rights in
mind are you mean talk with me oh there
goes stop driving this way it's a really
bad idea
too late we're committed
[Music]
CS player plays vowel just keep that as
our title for advert I just want to play
the game you know Jack question mark 70
K subs oh my god what the sex is looking
so can you ever seen this will never be
topped this is the peak of my career
[Music]
right now summits the camp twitch the
csgo og shot to the top of the site and
he's pulling in insane numbers whenever
he goes live he's living on most viewers
dream but for a while that dream felt
like a nightmare to him a nightmare
fueled by one cartoony battle royale no
this stupid game for night was a global
phenomenon the game was everywhere
including twitch and everybody wanted to
watch it so somewhat obliged
you gotta get off before it blows up
baby
but he quickly grew tired of the game
what started out as enjoyment turned
into a mind-numbing chore to appease
viewers one that torrid is sanity
there's got to be a different good way
for me in the twitch world that go down
this fortnight line man it's the most
boring date on the planet dude how do
you guys like this game so much
oh it's boring his ball sack dude I'm
dying here
can sweating from boredom how do you
play this game every day eventually
summit said screw it and took a break
from streaming and when he returned he
brought with him a new mindset he was
done sacrificing his mental health for
viewership done chasing the next flavor
of the month some it was gonna play the
games he wanted to play not just the
ones that brought the most views and
this type of variety streaming but
summit back to a game everyone thought
was dead what's going on dudes thank you
guys for tuning into the stream good
morning good afternoon good evening can
hey myself right now
lured back into the game after an update
summit revived sea of thieves on Twitch
with his funny antics chin yo kid what'd
I tell you man no singing Pro it's over
those streams started with decent
viewership and they just kept growing
everyone wanted to see what kind of
naval trouble some it was gonna get into
that day
what the what
huh what does happen but one can only
plunder ships for so long and so
eventually summit moved back into
variety streaming sometimes going back
to his roots with first-person shooters
brothers you are not gonna believe what
the guy just did all I meant to do was
shoot that glass open and there was a
guy there I just wanted to shoot the
glass open bro
I didn't mean to shoot the guy man I
didn't know he was there until after I
shot huh other times he felt like
running around Los Santos getting
himself into all sorts of weird
situations in GTA RP I have to [ __ ]
keep track of that money I can't [ __ ] it
ok ok I gotta get that to be any later
alright gotta get used to go into this
house right there sure it's okay man oh
my god
bah get the [ __ ] out of my way cease his
cries
most recently though somewhat caught the
valent bug and he's been streaming the
new shooters closed beta non-stop right
there for an old csgo head like him
valor n't is right up his alley
you think about the molotov in this game
is if you're playing phoenix you're
molotovs hurt your teammates they hurt
your enemies but they heal you I've been
I've been waiting to tell you guys that
for so long
I've been waiting to tell you guys that
for so long imagine me having to wait to
tell you guys that we don't have to
worry about the Molotov from ourselves
but it's not just having fun with the
game he's dominating the valence section
on Twitch as the game's number one
streamer Jack questionmark 70k subs oh
my god let the sexy sleepin sub can
you've ever seen this will never be
topped this is the peak of my career
career okay hob it's the peak of my
online hobby
did I do the guy is putting up monster
numbers during the first week of the
closed beta he was peeking at over
200,000 concurrent viewers a day either
to watch him play or to try to get into
the closed beta themselves why don't we
do this why don't we destroy safety
saves it finally in now he has player
plays vowel talk about drops bat you
know there for you guys they get me
viewership that's cool but you know like
I just want to play the [ __ ] game you
don't give a [ __ ] while the massive
viewership is nice the guy just wants to
have fun ten seconds left
don't they have to plant whether he's
fragging out in shooters or playing less
popular titles summits playing what he
wants to play and viewers him and love
it bro summits become Twitter's top
streamer and all it took to get there
was remembering to have a little bit of
fun thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages